Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: eric vautier
Maya Chollet : Moi, c’est Maya.
J’ai commencé la montagne
dans le sac de mes parents
avant même de savoir marcher.
Voix d’homme : « Faces nord »,
un podcast de la RTS.
(Bruits de pas dans la neige)
Maya Chollet : C’est raide et stressant.
Il faut avoir confiance
parce qu’il n’y a pas beaucoup
de possibilités de s’assurer.
La face nord de l’Eiger,
la face nord du Cervin,
la face nord des Grandes Jorasses.
Ces trois faces réputées infranchissables
où des dizaines d’alpinistes
ont perdu la vie.
Elles ont finalement été gravies
dans les années 30.
Une épopée en haute montagne,
une aventure humaine.
J’ai eu envie de la vivre, cette aventure,
de me lancer dans ces faces nord,
sur les traces de ces pionniers qui ont
écrit la grande histoire de l’alpinisme.
Voix d’homme : En 1936, trois cordées
indépendantes les unes des autres
sont au pied de la face.
Maya Chollet : La face nord,
la difficulté suprême en alpinisme.
Le froid, la glace, le risque.
Les chutes de pierre.
Parfois, la mort.
Qu’est-ce qui me fascine
tant sur ces montagnes ?
Pourquoi risquer sa vie ainsi ?
Peut-être parce que là-haut,
on se sent vivre
comme nulle part ailleurs.
« Faces Nord »,
bien au-delà d’une ascension,
le projet de toute une vie.
(Musique)
(Applaudissements)
Bonsoir à toutes ! Bonsoir à tous !
Ce que vous venez d’entendre,
c’est le début d’une longue aventure
qui m’a emmenée bien
au-delà des montagnes,
bien au-delà de ce que j’avais prévu.
Parce qu’oser, c’est prendre un risque,
c’est s’exposer.
C'est se jeter à l'eau.
C’est se lancer dans une aventure qui peut
prendre un peu plus de temps que prévu,
beaucoup plus d’énergie que prévu.
Et surtout, qui peut vous amener
bien plus loin que prévu.
Mais avant tout, je voulais
revenir au début de l’histoire
parce que pour moi, faire de la montagne,
ça n’a pas toujours été une évidence.
Donc, pour ceux qui ne me
connaissent pas ou pas encore,
moi, c’est Maya.
J’ai grandi à 30 kilomètres d’ici,
à Palézieux-Village.
C’est chez les Vaudois,
ne le dites pas trop fort.
Et comme vous venez de l’entendre,
j’ai commencé la montagne
dans le sac à dos de mes parents.
Avant même de savoir marcher.
Ils nous emmenaient partout.
Et quand j’ai eu huit ans,
la vie m’a choisi un autre chemin.
J’ai perdu ma maman
dans un accident d’escalade.
Mon père a rangé les cordes, les piolets.
Et moi, j’ai commencé la natation
parce qu’on est d’accord, nager,
c’est quand même bien moins risqué.
Ensuite, j’ai fait
plusieurs années de sport.
J’aime bien dire : à haut niveau
mais à basse altitude.
Du trail, du triathlon,
des coupes du monde.
Mais quelque part, les montagnes
étaient toujours au fond de moi,
quelque part en ligne de mire.
Par contre, il fallait oser
s'en approcher de nouveau.
Les années ont passé,
je suis devenue journaliste à la RTS.
J’ai commencé à faire
des reportages sur la montagne.
Je m’en approchais un tout petit peu.
Un jour, le producteur de l’émission
« Altitudes » où je travaillais m’a dit :
« Maya, tu ne nous ferais pas un reportage
sur une grimpeuse, une guide ?
Elle fait de la grimpe, Nicole Berthod.
Tu vas grimper avec,
ça va faire un chouette reportage. »
Alors, j’y suis allée avec ma peur.
On a fait une voie à plusieurs longueurs
et dans l’avant-dernière, d’un coup,
je m’en rappelle très bien,
je me suis dit :
« Mais c’est ça que j’ai envie
de faire, je veux grimper.
Je veux aller dans les montagnes. »
Sauf que le problème,
c’est que je ne savais rien faire.
Je ne savais pas faire un nœud,
j’ai dû tout apprendre.
Le vocabulaire bizarre de l’alpinisme :
becquet, les spits, vacher, les dégaines,
les techniques de corde.
Les codes de ce milieu un peu étrange.
Et surtout, j’ai dû apprendre
à dompter ma peur.
Parce que pour moi,
depuis que j’étais enfant,
escalade, ça voulait dire
dangereux, accident et mort.
Au fil des années, j'ai commencé à faire
des courses de plus en plus dures.
J’ai fait de plus en plus
de reportages aussi sur la montagne,
chaque fois que je pouvais.
Et un jour, j’ai vu un appel à projets
de la RTS pour des podcasts.
C’était ouvert à tout le monde,
pas qu’aux employés.
Et mes collègues m’ont dit :
« Maya, propose un truc montagne. »
J’étais là : « Podcast,
je sais à peine ce que ça veut dire.
Et je n’ai aucune idée. C’est non. »
Deux jours après,
j’étais chez un ami, guide de montagne,
qui a travaillé 30 ans dans les secours
et dans sa bibliothèque, j’ai vu un livre,
« Les trois derniers
problèmes des Alpes. »
J’ai pris le livre, je l’ai ouvert.
Et là, c’est comme tout
un pan de ma vie qui a basculé.
Dans ce livre, ça racontait
l’histoire de l’alpinisme
parce que dans les années 30-40,
toutes les montagnes avaient été gravies
par tous les côtés
possibles et imaginables.
Il restait trois trucs que les alpinistes
de l’époque n’arrivaient pas à faire.
La face nord du Cervin,
la face nord des Jorasses
et la face nord de l’Eiger.
Et à cette époque,
il y avait des alpinistes,
courageux ou complètement fous -
la frontière est souvent
assez mince entre les deux -
qui s’élançaient dans ces faces
pour tenter d’être les premiers au sommet,
avec souvent la mort à la clé.
Ces trois derniers problèmes,
aujourd’hui encore,
pour beaucoup d’alpinistes,
c’est le projet de toute une vie.
Là, je me suis dit :
« Voilà ce qu’il faut faire.
C'est ça l'idée.
Raconter l’histoire
des trois problèmes des Alpes.
On va aller dans les faces nord
et raconter ce qu’on vit
quand on est dans ces parois.
La peur, le froid, les joies, les doutes,
les questions qu’on se pose quand on est
suspendu là-haut dans ces montagnes.
Et aussi partager aux auditeurs
les valeurs universelles qui nous
guident dans ces montagnes :
l’entraide, l’esprit de cordée,
l’engagement, le courage. »
Parfait.
Le soir-même, trois heures,
j’ai écrit mon projet et je l’ai envoyé.
Je me suis dit : « De toute façon,
je n’ai aucune chance, c’est trop risqué,
trop cher, ça dure trop longtemps.
Aucune chance. »
Quelques mois plus tard,
c’était le jour de mon anniversaire,
un vendredi.
J’étais à la salle d’escalade.
Dehors, il pleuvait des hectolitres.
Je reçois un mail de mon chef :
« Chère Maya,
nous avons le plaisir de t’annoncer
que ton projet a été retenu »
parmi les cent cinquante
qu’ils avaient reçus.
Et là, je me souviens,
il y a eu un moment de flottement.
J’ai regardé les prises
au-dessus de ma tête et j’étais là :
« Ok, il va falloir s’entraîner. »
Je ne vais pas vous raconter ici
tout le podcast « Faces Nord ».
C’est une aventure qui a duré trois ans.
Je pourrais en parler pendant trois jours.
Je vais plutôt faire la journaliste
et vous poser une question.
Pour vous, c’est quoi, le courage ?
Pour moi, le courage,
c’est oser prendre un risque.
C’est accepter de s’exposer,
c’est agir sans savoir ce qui nous attend.
Mais depuis « Faces Nord »,
pour moi, le courage, c’est bien plus.
C’est accepter avec humilité.
C'est résister à la pression.
Et c’est savoir renoncer.
Et je vais vous raconter
avec trois moments de cette aventure,
comment j’en suis arrivée
à cette conclusion.
Le premier moment,
on allait partir
dans la face nord du Cervin.
Les créneaux pour ces faces nord,
c’est souvent deux ou trois jours
par année, parfois pas du tout.
Donc, il ne faut pas rater le coche.
On allait partir dans le Cervin.
On était en forme, acclimatés, prêts.
Tout le monde était là.
Il faisait beau, tous les feux verts.
Et deux jours avant le départ,
j’ai reçu un coup de téléphone
où on m’annonçait le décès de deux amis
dans la face nord du Cervin.
Et là, il y a un moment
où beaucoup de questions
vous passent dans la tête.
On y va ou on n’y va pas ?
On s’est vu le soir-même
à la cafétéria avec mes collègues.
On a décidé d’enregistrer la discussion.
Et là, il m’a fallu du courage
pour accepter que mes tripes
me disent de ne pas y aller
et pour accepter
de partager cette discussion.
Le deuxième moment.
On était à peu près à une année
du début du projet.
Ça faisait une année qu’on tentait
les faces nord et ça ne marchait pas.
On faisait demi-tour,
il faisait moche, il y avait un blessé.
Une vraie catastrophe.
Et gentiment, on a commencé
à ressentir ce que je pourrais appeler
une pression médiatique,
où on nous demandait
de sortir la première saison
même si on n’avait aucune face,
ce n’était pas si grave.
Pour moi, c’était hors de question.
On ne peut pas sortir, diffuser,
publier un podcast « Faces Nord »
quand on a fait aucune
des trois faces nord.
Et surtout,
j’ai l’impression qu’en montagne,
quand on vend un sommet
qu’on n’a pas encore fait,
ça vous pousse à y aller toute votre vie,
à prendre tous les risques
pour vous montrer
à la hauteur de la promesse.
Et ça, c’est une pression
dont je ne voulais pas,
ni pour moi, ni pour l’équipe,
ni pour les guides, ni pour personne.
Il m’a fallu du courage
pour résister à la pression.
Le troisième moment.
On était dans la face nord
de l’Eiger pour la deuxième fois
parce qu’on avait déjà fait une fois
demi-tour à cause de la neige.
On était dans la face nord de l’Eiger,
tout allait bien, il faisait chaud.
On venait de passer une nuit incroyable
dans un bivouac incroyable,
60 cm de haut à trois
et serrés comme des sardines comme ça.
On a super bien dormi.
Deuxième journée, on arrivait
à la hauteur du bivouac de la mort.
Tout d’un coup, le guide se tourne vers
moi et dit : « Maya, on fait demi-tour. »
Je le regarde et je dis :
« Mais non, attends,
on est plein d’énergie,
pourquoi on ferait demi-tour ? »
Rien compris.
Il me dit : « Regarde au-dessus de nous.
Il y a quatorze personnes.
Quatorze personnes,
ça veut dire 50% de risque
de se prendre des cailloux dans la figure.
Sûrement que tout ira bien,
sûrement que tout pourrait bien aller.
Mais moi, en montagne,
je ne joue pas à la loterie. »
Et là, il a fallu du courage.
Du courage pour renoncer.
Alors que tout allait bien.
On a fait demi-tour.
Trois nouvelles formes de courage :
le courage d’accepter,
le courage de résister à la pression,
et le courage de renoncer.
Au final, dans « Faces Nord »,
on a décidé de raconter
tout ce qui fonctionne
mais surtout,
tout ce qui n’a pas fonctionné.
Et il y en a eu, des choses
qui n’ont pas fonctionné.
Je ne sais pas vous mais sur
dix trucs que j’entreprends,
je pense qu’il y en a neuf qui foirent.
Sauf que les gens sont incroyables.
Ils pensent que tout me réussit parce
qu’ils ne voient pas tout ce qui foire.
Je pense qu’on devrait plus
thématiser les échecs.
Mais vous et moi, on est tous pareils.
Raconter ce qu’on a raté,
franchement, on déteste.
Dans « Faces Nord »
à la fin de la première saison,
on a décidé d’arrêter après
le premier demi-tour à l’Eiger
et on m’a reproché de raconter
une aventure qui rate.
Au final, ce qu’on a voulu
raconter dans « Faces Nord »,
c’est ces décisions courageuses qu’on est
tous amenés à prendre un jour dans sa vie,
dans sa vie professionnelle,
dans sa vie privée.
C'est toutes ces questions qu'on se pose,
qu'on va être amené à se poser une fois.
Qu’est-ce qu’on est prêt à risquer
pour un projet, une idée, un rêve ?
Jusqu’où on est prêt à s’exposer ?
Jusqu’où on est prêt à s’engager ?
Qu’est-ce qu’on est prêt à surmonter ?
Qu’est-ce qu’on est prêt à oser ?
Le projet « Faces nord » m’a fait vivre
des choses d’une intensité indescriptible.
Il m’a fait faire tout ce que je déteste,
tout ce qui me fait peur :
renoncer, des demi-tours,
parler des échecs,
parler devant vous ce soir.
Mais il m’a surtout appris à garder le cap
malgré les doutes, malgré le froid.
Malgré les accidents.
Il m’a offert une leçon de vie
que j’avais envie de partager
avec vous ce soir.
Et j'ai envie de vous laisser
avec une phrase.
L’important, plus que de réussir,
c’est d’oser.
Bon courage.
(Applaudissements)